if you follow politics if you work in
politics if you report on politics you
generally understand that every American
president through foreign policy makes
decisions that lead to people dying it
could be a drone strike it could be
cutting key medical aid to another
country it could be sending people to
war so through foreign policy presidents
cause death
that's not a new thing but the Trump
administration has turned deadly in a
way that is different in a way that is
much more easily preventable
Elizabeth drew wrote a really good
article about this for Project Syndicate
and she points out that the Trump
administration has turned deadly
simply because Donald Trump ignored
readily available advice from scientists
and other knowledgeable advisors from
day one on the issue of coronavirus
Donald Trump was told about the risks of
doing nothing back in December and
January and now he says nobody knew
nobody could have imagined Trump was
given the pandemic playbook by the Obama
administration colour-coded 69 pages and
ignored it and now says nobody could
have expected this but we know
intelligence agencies were warning him
science agencies were warning him public
health agencies were telling him what
was potentially coming and he also had
been briefed his administration had been
briefed by the outgoing Obama
administration in 2017 on exactly how to
deal with a pandemic and Trump never
focused on it and he always ignored it
he dismissed the virus he said it
wouldn't be worse than the flu he said
we had 15 cases which would soon be zero
he bragged that nobody had died he said
it's under control and of course it was
all wrong and it has been deadly Trump
could have just not invoked but utilized
the defense production act a while ago
to force the production of much needed
medical supplies but he was successfully
lobbied by
the Chamber of Commerce and Industry not
to do that and so he waited and waited
and we fell further and further behind
he didn't mobilize the federal stockpile
of ventilators and other supplies later
having his son-in-law Jared Kushner
claim in dystopian fashion that the
stockpile is ours not the states in a
very sinister ominous press briefing
last Thursday and all of this led to far
more death than necessary Trump played
favorites with states regularly we get
reports that red state governors were
getting everything they asked for in
terms of supplies and equipment while
many blue state governors were not and
Trump continued and continues to blame
systems he inherited which is code for
blame Obama Trump is negotiating in some
cases against States for medical
supplies that those states need while
insisting states have to go out and get
their stuff and blaming States for
shortages that they experienced Trump is
regularly using war language to try to
weaponize the virus as a political tool
for re-election and so the decisions
that he makes have always been primarily
influenced by political calculations and
political expediency and in the
background of all of this we hear lame
economic arguments made which
essentially are arguments that say it's
okay for more people should die in
exchange for the economy the economy is
meant to be open the country is meant to
be open the Cure cannot be worse than
the disease or we can't allow it to be
worse than the disease and of course
this ignores the reality that from day
one if we had had a proper six-week
shutdown we would have prevented the
need for these overlapping partial
shutdowns
that still are going to do economic
damage but won't actually fix the
problem once and for all it's almost
impossible to do a worse job than Donald
Trump did many small business owners I
know
people who just run a restaurant would
have been able to manage this better
than Donald Trump given all of the
resources that he had at his disposal
many of which he chose to
more and if you want to play the
business game any modest humble you know
professor I had in business school would
have been able to manage this better
than Donald Trump because most of people
who actually understand business and are
good at business understand the
importance of deferring to experts which
Donald Trump seems essentially unable to
do any doctor who runs a medical
practice would have managed this better
than Donald Trump
if Trump had done nothing other than to
say I am appointing a coronavirus czar
like Ronald clean maybe Barack Obama's
Ebola czar and just let them handled it
let them handle it and stayed out of it
we would be far better off so yes
presidents lead to death through foreign
policy and through domestic policy in a
lot of different ways but the Trump
presidency has now become deadly in a
way that is very different than what we
normally say when we say presidents lead
to death through foreign policy it's
very very ugly and we don't yet know how
bad it's going to get